[Music]
do you need to run scalable batch jobs
without the overhead of managing
everything that comes with it are you
concerned about optimizing resources to
match your batch job's needs or
flexibility when it comes to cost and
resource availability
come along as i introduce you to the
latest google cloud product for batch
job scheduling
batch
parallel computing tasks like rendering
transcoding scientific workflows and
risk modeling are laborious
time-consuming and often there's little
flexibility when you're running these
tasks
batch jobs can require complicated setup
like hosting of job schedulers managing
the servers building custom auto scalers
and often you bear the burden of
managing both the queue of jobs and the
life cycle of the infrastructure
this management can lead to an
exponential amount of unnecessary
overhead that dedicated resources would
be needed to look after
google has a history of developing
products that serve these computing
needs and deal with some complexities
that come with them
and now we're excited to introduce one
more that hits a few sweet spots that
you have asked for
google cloud proudly presents batch
a fully managed job scheduler to help
you run thousands of batch jobs with a
single command
it's simple to use handles resources in
a more optimized way and makes running
batch jobs of any scale executable type
and job structure easy
batch is built to run workloads of any
size but it really shines with large
scale workloads
for long running jobs batch won't
timeout after a certain number of hours
and it'll run however long as needed to
complete the job you can specify a max
run duration at the individual task
level within the job to prevent hanging
or runaway tasks
one thing to note is if the run value is
exceeded the task will be marked as
failed but the task may be retried if
you specify a retry value
batch gives customers the ability to run
both containers and shell scripts as
jobs compared to some other batch
products available today which only
allow for containerized jobs
this means that if you have batch
scripts that are used on-prem which a
large amount of high-performance
computing workloads are
and need to run a job on the cloud you
don't have to first containerize it you
can just configure the script with batch
and run the job
when we say fully managed we mean it
you focus on the jobs to run while batch
takes care of the infrastructure
on the back end and optimizes vm life
cycles to run efficiently
and it's built on the cloud so it takes
advantage of the cloud capacity and is
elastic and flexible so that when you
need more capacity batch starts more vms
if they're available and when you need
less it runs less
plus compute engine has a flexible
pricing model that goes along with this
so you can leverage spot vms and custom
machine types to stay within your budget
to top it all off it's a cloud native
stack so it can easily be used with
other google cloud services like cloud
storage file store logging monitoring
workflows and cloud scheduler and batch
continues to expand upon the workflow
engines and tools that are supported
as i mentioned before batch works by
managing everything on the backend it
allocates machines resources like cpus
memory and gpus to set the right
configuration for batch workloads
like the spot vms i mentioned
it'll set up compute instances for you
schedule and queue up jobs retry tasks
within a job in case of failures and
adhere to the priorities you set all
while optimizing for cost and speed
all you need to do is define a job
submit it and monitor the results
let's walk through how to do that so you
can see just how simple the
configuration process is with a video
transcoding example
first we'll need to run this command to
enable the batch api
this is a requirement when you're using
batch for the first time in a project
then prepare a cloud storage bucket you
can use a cloud storage bucket to store
objects for batch jobs
make sure that you're in this
transcoding directory
you'll need to run these commands to
create a new bucket and copy tutorial
files to that bucket
replace project id and bucket name in
the command to whatever your project
name is and what you want the name of
your bucket to be i named mine nuggets
of buckets
you can see here that the video files
have been copied
next we need to define a job in batch a
job is a collection of tasks for this
tutorial we'll create a job that has a
task to encode video files with the vp9
code c compression format
go to the editor and under batch samples
transcoding you should see the job.json
file
open it in the editor change the bucket
name to the name of your bucket and then
save the file
the json file defines a job that runs
the
transcode.ssh script in spot n2d
standard four instances it also defines
how many resources the task can use such
as cpu memory and time
once we have the files saved we need to
submit the job to batch before we can
run it this command will submit a job
named transcode using the job.json file
we saved in the us central one region
when you're running your own job you can
replace transcode with the name of your
job and select the appropriate region
for your business
the output should look like this
and the first line should say job was
successfully submitted
so now the job is registered in the
system you can always check the current
status of a job by running this batch
jobs describe command
and the output should look like this
if the state is scheduled like we can
see here that means the job is scheduled
to run and batches preparing resources
such as spinning up a vm
the status will change to running once
batch is finished preparing the vms and
starts running the tasks defined in the
job
if you want to see the compute engine
instances that batch has created to run
the job you can run the command gcloud
compute instances list
and the output should look like this
the machine name will change every time
for this tutorial we're running a fairly
small job that should finish in about
five minutes the time it takes depends
on the complexity of the job
batch supports running jobs for hours
and even days when needed
you can see the progress of your job by
looking at the log in cloud logging
there are console outputs from the tasks
and compute engine operation history
managed by batch
you can also check if the job has
finished with the same gcloud command we
used before
the status should show succeeded when
the job has finished successfully
now you can check out the encoded video
files they'll be stored in the same
cloud storage bucket and there are two
ways that you could do this
either run this command
that displays a list of the encoded
video files
and then run this command making sure to
change the bucket name if you want to
download them
or you can browse the objects in your
bucket in the console
you'll find the new files in the output
directory inside the current directory
and you can open and watch them with
your chrome browser by clicking the
download arrows on the right here
once you finish with this you have a few
options
batch automatically deletes the
instances it creates for each job and
there is no charge to keep your job in
the history after it's completed however
you might still be charged for storing
the data for the job in cloud storage
you may want to keep the job in the
history so you can do some chargeback or
review periodically like at the end of
the month
or you may want to keep the job around
to compare certain jobs to one another
so
ultimately it's your choice on what the
best move is for you based on your
organization's needs
you can delete the batch job by running
the gcloud beta batch jobs delete
command
and that's all there is to it now you've
successfully defined and run a job in
batch on google cloud
batch is meant to relieve the burden for
customers like you managing third-party
batch schedulers open source frameworks
and orchestration software
batch manages the complex large-scale
stuff in the background so you save on
resources time and cost and can focus on
what's really important
your business
if you want to learn more check out the
product page public docs and the written
tutorial all linked in the description
thanks for watching
[Music]
you